تم عسكرة هذا الشريط الممتد على مساحة 160 ياردة والذي يفصل بين
شرق برلين وغربها
لعقود من الزمن ، وهو الآن مكان للكاريوكي ، وقد أصبحت
هذه القصة الكبيرة ممكنة
بفضل المجلس الوطني الألماني للسياحة
وتأمين السفر الأساسي لهانز زيمر الذي
كان في يوم من الأيام أخطر الحدود
في العالم  هي الآن موطنًا لمدرج
حيث يمكنك العثور على المئات من
محبي الكاريوكي من جميع أنحاء التجمع كل
يوم أحد بفضل هذا الرجل ، اسمي
يوهان فان ، أنا مؤسس
ومبدع الكاريوكي الملحمي
الجد كاريوكي هو كاريوكي في الهواء الطلق
لذلك أنا  بدأ الاستعداد للكاريوكي في
أواخر الشتاء ، وأوائل ربيع عام 2009
يحدث في مدرج في حديقة
تسمى مارا بارك في منطقة برنس ألبرت
في برلين في حوالي الساعة الثالثة
بعد ظهر يوم الأحد عندما يكون الطقس
جيدًا وأظهر مع حمولة دراجة من
المعدات  وقمنا بإعداده في غضون
دقيقتين من العمل السهل ، فنحن نبحث
عن أول شيء لدينا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المغنيون الهواة يأتون من أماكن بعيدة
ويتباهون بأنابيبهم
تجمع لعبة Bear pit حدث mauerpark الناس
معًا من جميع أنحاء العالم ، فأنت في
الواقع تسمع عددًا أقل من الغناء الألماني مقارنة
بالناس من هولندا ، والأشخاص من
إفريقيا ، والأشخاص من أمريكا اللاتينية ، والناس
من أمريكا الشمالية ، والناس الأيرلنديون ،
لذا فهو مكان رائع جدًا
أحب  تشعر عندما تذهب إلى
هناك ، تغني أمام
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص ويبدأون في الغناء
معك ولا أعرف خارج هذا
العالم
على الرغم من الماضي المروع للمنطقة أو
ربما
بسببه يوضح mauerpark رغبة الألمان وأهالي
برلين في ذلك.  مواجهة
التاريخ والعمل معًا للمضي قدمًا في
كل مورد يصف هذا
بأنه نوع من الأشياء التي تناسب
فكرة برلين عن اللحظات الخاصة التي
حدثت على مر السنين بالنسبة لي هناك
عندما يكون الجميع
أكثر من مجرد انقسام  ثانيًا ،
في نفس الصفحة ، تعلم أننا جميعًا
نُصاب ببثور الإوزة في نفس الوقت وكلنا
يعلم أن شيئًا ما هو أو كان
مميزًا جدًا
[موسيقى]